let me ask you a big perhaps ridiculous
question but give it a shot
what is the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life
the big question i'm not going to rush
into the answer
i'm gonna give you somebody else answer
first and i'll give you my answer
i remember asking this
and uh
you know i was 15 16 years old one of
the brothers
you know was studying in mathematics
and
the letter i itself
was
means i
islam
i mean in the individual
right
being a total
accord with islam
let me just finish this then they took
the word islam and they defined it
that islam
is an arabic word
for peace
then they said peace
is the absence
of confusion
okay
so
then they took this this is something
that really hit me when i was and i
never forgot it and i
i'm not going to decipher it but then
they took the word islam
and they broke it down by the letter
into a acronym like casual everything
around me
and they broke it down to i
stimulate
light
and matter
and i was like
because what hit me is that if you're
not here
then light and matter don't exist to you
so you're stimulating it
or they ain't here for you
so anyway taking all that so then i said
you know so what's the meaning of life
and the brothers just said love it's
long forever
right yeah people know that i ain't
saying the religious point of view i'm
just saying all those other elements i
just spoke about in front of it i
stimulate light and matter i love that
that's powerful
and let me give you my definition of
life
i think life
is that simple
lead for each and every one of us to add
on to
build like you said the masters
build on top life gave you life give
life back
i don't think there's a better way to
end it than talking about the meaning of
life reza i'm a huge fan of such a huge
honor that you spend your valuable time
with me thank you so much
you